nein also ich will mussten warten
sie machen soll ich muss irgendwas typ
aktive
haye zu warm und herzlich willkommen
zurück beim mega projekt natürlich was
ich jetzt wird ich jetzt machen wollte
ist jetzt fliegt in richtung stadt also
muss die 100 meter kurz abwarten die
flieger setzen also und ich suche
selbstverständlich bienenstöcke die
rockies sind wenn ich wüsste wo ich
rocke bienenstöcke finde denn ich bin ja
schon eine extreme hitze und hier sind
keine rocky bienenstöcke brauche aber
rocky bienen
ich hab mir schon extra ich habe es gibt
sogar bienen mit denen ich später
diamanten züchten kann sowie alle er
direkt auf meinem weg punkt draufstehe
steht trotzdem home sweet home ein meter
davon entfernt
ich habe schon wieder vergessen was
machen wollte und scanner hafens keller
schlafen richtig die reinheit binder ab
in den ofen eisgekühlter bommerlunder
dazu 22 belegt als mit schicken 1 mit
ist dass das irgendwie so ging das
schlafen und ich unter eis gekühlt ja
was los ich kaufe für zwei euro fünfzig
blumen wie viele blumen habe ich 250
kommst du blut kommen viele blumen
kostet kann man sagen ich hoffe für zwei
euro fünfzig blumen
oder er sagt viele blumen ich habe so
viele blumen wir einem warenwert von 250
entspricht nein man kann man weiß
wieviel blumig habe wenn man mal
nachdenkt ach so du kommst du zwei euro
fünfzig fünfzig wichtig du bist die
person bisher am schnellsten drauf
gekommen
hast du denn ich hab' ich hab nur ein
ich brauche auf jeden fall noch mehr
deswegen muss mir ich hab über 14 26
da habe ich schlechte erfahrungen du
weißt du weißt du weißt doch einfach
nehmen kann
die fackel brauche ich auch nicht das ei
kommt da auch hier zu suchen
das ist komisch da rechts im team sind
wir da steht keiner hat mit der pille
die und wenn ich das kraftrad dass keine
versuche ich wäre das hat ja auch
energie ist irgendwie falsch modus drin
darf ich
wir brauche ich mein glas dann staub von
dir
ich bin ja warum
wünsche dir ja das ist geld also
wohlgemerkt was ich hab's aufgenommen
aber ich hab's nicht invent a chip
hennes nicht da eine ganze kiste ist er
wieder voll mit scheiße ohne ach das ist
in meinem bergbauarbeiter druck sagt
klar
die ganze kiste ist voll mit alter aber
so richtig ich habe wieder glaube ich
hier gehirne 20.6 kabel grad raus holten
dann liegen immer noch 40 6 oder so
richtig wie kers gehirn nur kabel drin
alter nur kabel drin amtieren nur kabel
drin
conne 1 bis auf jeden fall gleich wieder
ordentlich ackern
ja es nur ich hab kein holz für kisten
aufgefallen ich habe selten braucht man
einfach nicht einfach mal vier stunden
megaprojekt auf jungs richtig bock in
die gerade ohne willst einfach mal holz
fahren hast du überhaupt keinen bock auf
aufnehmen die texte auch vollmundig
jetzt muss ich mal nachdenken rubber und
ich brauche gold gold für marvin nichts
machen
scheiße wenn du mir in goldbarren oder
zwei oder drei gibt's dann welche
zufrieden da kann ich auch heute dankbar
in alter stärke was sonst wohin er
fahren aber das ist viel zu wertvoll
ja man nicht auch anbieten
richtige gold
ich möchte gar nicht
die lebensfreude für holz seien jetzt
kommen so freude jetzt den tipp von
allen ich muss die wache mit rausnehmen
dann kriegst meinten alle und geht's ich
warte gerade kurz also jetzt mache ich
mir so wie es aussieht wie platz mehr
hat
das ist so in einer kiste ja doch ich
bekomme xperia duo
okay das leben immer mit so viel gold
gerade das bei manchen kreisen kisten
leiter scheiß auf alles besitz alters
altar wieviel karlstor komm gib mir ein
eigenes der carlson ist ein ganzes also
los ich hab selber zehn kisten voll mit
kabel stone nein ich will reisen haben
ich habe kein einziges mal ist halt
gemacht
ich war auf einmal sein gold sucht
einfach nicht diskutieren nein nein nein
ich will dass haben
ich habe mir schon so gedachten
eigentlich schon gut danach die gold das
besser aber ich hab ja auch sehr viel
kraft ihr ins feld lust und stellt es
gibt endlich sie ist ja auch immer
deutlich mehr platz das war ein sehr
guter tipp da muss ich echt mal loben
das ist fantastisch ich mensch das ist
fantastisch dass ich in meinem leben
noch mal gelobt werde du kommt auch
nicht an bezahlen
ich brauche ein adventstag electronics
tag habe ich nicht noch einmal das
gefühl alle über sie immer weiter
möglich du mir vorstellen das niveau von
anfang an von wem winken kompakt ms in
ms niveau wir sinken gesehen was ist
anders ich so etwas ist ein anderes kann
ich mir auf einmal kann auch kann man
reisen kisten auch übereinander setzen
ja auch nebeneinander also mehr wald
normale kisten gehe ja nicht
übereinander hat so übereinander gesetzt
wann genau mit gucken
ich war mit einer mega viele eisen
kisten scheiß auf alles wirklich denkt
er einfach
zwei riesige kiste war eisenberg
geworfen wo ist meine kiste kommt
fahrzeug klosterstadt kommt hier hin da
der ud scanner so ich habe jetzt einen
sketch begeisterung für mich
funktioniert dankeschön schlechtes
gewalt bauen das hätte ich war so ein
bisschen mäßig das direkte main event
schutz die reinen puste gespuckt kannst
du auch zusammen mit schmuck und in
essen resten von gestern abend und alles
ist einfach damit eingegangen so ich bin
natürlich ganz spendabel mit meinem
beruf ausgedrückt 49 ganz genau ich
stehe auf meinem grundstück 49 ist gar
nichts
kürzlich ist praktisch gerettet was
hattest du denn wann ist etwas mehr
platz 80 lohnte sich unter zu gehen
runter zu gehen ich dachte jetzt das in
der höhle gemacht nein ich ganz oben auf
der oberfläche wenn ich irgendwann sehr
80 top sein gegner mining laser auch für
8 und karat diamanten und da sind
eigentlich ziemlich häufig fläche 55 du
hast ja kein mining laser zu machen
geht
die apparatur ist aber er lohnt sich da
lohnt sich echt was für ressourcen bin
ich deine mama jetzt mit den eisen
kisten das war eine fantastische idee
habe ich gleich schneetief mehr
ich bin also ich will muss wahrlich weit
lieber die machen leute
ich muss jetzt irgendwas typ aktiv
marien mining laser ja genau was ich
hier stehen ob es trinkst bekommst du
wenn du fragst anbaus tanga bekommt den
textilwaren liebe bekommen diese
bekommst du wie normales gras sehr
schneidig und max 12 3 11
also das ist echt ein guter tipp und
flachs lohnt sich mal durst trinkt
bekommt sie wirklich auch etwas
verzaubern sind oder für wolle oder was
das neue post für alle war bei der show
nicht auf dem offenen 56
ich habe jetzt hier wirklich gerade so
viele kisten in eisen verwandeln und ich
glaube es lohnt sich
ich glaube es lohnt sich ein bisschen
schluss machte jetzt endlich zu ende
passiert wenn es aufgebaut dass diese
komische kauz muss ja auch im wasser an
waren die flexi ahlen eine christin ja
ganz normal wie sieht's history and wo
seid ihr ich liebe euch so sehr dass er
fragen beantworten talent sagen
wassereimer löffel
denn die wären einmal erfunden hat oder
eine büroklammer oder irgendwie sowas
die sind jetzt von unseren
provisorischen spawn ja immer noch sehr
feuerwehr ist wirklich vom allerfeinsten
muss man einfach zu sagen es steht nicht
so viel liebe und das mit viel mühe
gegeben aber richtig hart gearbeitet
dass er den elfer nicht alles machen
nicht wett
mal zum bürgermeister gewählt die
us-importe noch gar keinen bürgermeister
hat mit den schülern der bisher einmal
aufgehört
dann braucht ihr auch niemanden mehr
hier morgen dort niemanden ins
formaufbau das finde ich jetzt ehrlich
gesagt ein bisschen bockig freunde wer
braucht eigentlich kämpfen diesem
projekt was ist geeinigt capital der
quoten benutzt jeder der jetzt der
knoten spazieren projekt wir brauchen
keine dummes voten der haut die quoten
die alten jonas normal ist voll von
wolfgang ja wer beim voll folgen
ich nehme jetzt erstmal schön meine
alberne feld hatte wenn wir jemanden in
minecraft datei machen würde besitzt
ganzen vormittag versucht
du willst du machen und ich glaube ich
wird das wenn man sonnenfeld men band
hält ganz einfach macht mutter und sohn
soundtrack machen oder sich jetzt so
auch die eier gehen irgendwann richtig
durchkneten die richtige antwort sich
schon eine eigene kiste hat er richtig
gedacht gehste schlafen weil will willst
du das schlafen hier begegne ich ja
nicht vom star wochentag als das mache
ich jetzt mal so eiskalt sich jetzt auch
durch die nazis ehrlich gesagt okay das
panieren unterwegs giftig jetzt bin ich
unterwegs
ich komme da wir mit ihm eine laser
durch seine kisten schließen darf ich
meine frau mein gesicht hauen
ok du darfst du aber schlagen arbeite
meist durch den kisten schießen ok mit
der faust mit den nanos aber ich hätte
ich mit nano seiten das gleiche thema
miteinander selber geschlagen wie sage
ich will alles wäre geile aktion wollen
wir durch zu schießen
ja das bringt
nein nein ich freue mich ich habe klar
doch auch will gar nicht sagt plank
ich bin hier der soziale diesen die
asozialen die anderen da klappt gar kein
knochen mehr als lax
ich bin der soziale ja alles schön kev
klasse der serie a service lachs wächst
auf drei hohe sowie im zucker und du
kannst nur die oberste ebene abbauen
so läuft der hase haben wir fan nah gut
jetzt im bett oder müssen wir noch
bockig beim boxster die fackel mir alles
fertig sein anwalt will ich sehen
leg dich einfach
max ehrentag die scheinbar freundlich
schon mal ganz gut was ich noch was wenn
du dann brauchst komplett in misrata
dank an den sie siehst du ein bildschirm
gar nicht
ich guck doch mal deswegen sehe ich
nicht dass du mich pumpt sie keine kate
mccann ist recht gut was aber echt viel
regen habe ich sein sollte angebaut
jetzt geh in dein bett ich wünsche
weggeflogen von updates kommen nicht
hier
wie also kann es nicht kennen
9.35 das ist auch keine ausbeute das
kürze alles 446 alter kann ich auch
aufgrund steinigen scanner nutzen 41
meine güte ist alles schon ausgefüllt so
conny 1 jetzt kannst du wieder arbeiten
30 30
das ist weniger als bei dir auf dem
grundstück ist ein schickes ja schon
wertlos das war 58 auf dem das haus
steht den hut drauf dass ich jetzt ist
es sinnvoller das geschieht ja typisch
däne hat war wirklich wirklich besser
wenn stars aber nicht ausschlagen du
legst dich in bordeaux sie gerät sachse
was du knackst und locken mich aus
du bist doch statt wurde aber nicht eine
frage der quoten vom server gehen dieses
mal runter bis zum bett ich bin auf weg
da hatte ich gern schon mal verpassen im
letzten jahr schon so lange war aber
nicht in die pötte kommt ich glaube
jetzt im bett ok alles klar
umsätze der karge worden sein
und schauen auf dem bett was drogen hast
gelogen hast du was ich bin jetzt hier
und jetzt komm ich was mache ich mir da
ich würde gerne in den navara um den
großbauern holen
allerdings ist das bei mir einfach
sorgen um eisbär ich habe jetzt winter
eine bescheidene prinzessin leider die
falschen
ich brauche mein haus auch einfach so
viel klasse das ist normal
also das ist so selten das achterwasser
selten diamanten sind wir ganz nah am
scan und über immer nur 50 70 60 gar
nicht zu glauben
wer hat denn ein portal wo man relativ
sicher rauskommen du hast auch ein
portal über die machbarkeit jetzt mal
bei denen nicht einmal 69 und dann kommt
auf einmal links da 41 sind das nicht
ohne witz und ich kann jetzt schon
wieder zurück 500 meter und bin dumm
gelaufen und hab keine die ersten kunden
die leute sagt mir wie ich diese kacke
fixen kann das kann nicht sein
keine bösen russen hier dass ein
arbeitsmodus
es stehen aber das ist echt cool
eigentlich dass er sich nicht auf lädt
das ist auch unlogisch fallen daher
nicht schön dass bei denen er voll cool
irgendwie cool gebaut
59 23 das ist wertlos 44 13 13
in dem ganzen quadranten den ich
gecheckt haben sind nur 3 1 oder so
alltag chronik wird reicht ein bisschen
oder wieso da hat er einfach mal
komplett 30 kisten oder so nebeneinander
und 30 doppel kisten und alles voll mit
sachen alles voll mit sachen alles voll
mit ärzten wo alte kerry gebaut oder so
was ist nicht schlecht mit gewarnt dass
in jungle oder sehe ich das ist es was
ich nicht verstehe in dem empfiehlt es
sich so ich geh jetzt in den neckar und
ich hoffe ich komme da heile rein du
musst ein jetpack voll aufgeladen dann
aber fliegen was geht das geht
als ich dachte schon ist das lager und
dann sehe ich auf einmal diesem tag
bewegt sich der sache richtig krank ist
gehirn stein oder so ich schaue jetzt
mal ganz gut
hahaha da war die rettungsaktion werden
dahingestellt
wie weit nach hinten erweitert
ausgesehen bei zornig richtig weiter
hinten erweitert mit der richtig
gearbeitet
krass crystal defenders burgdorf korrekt
aber voll weit ins koma was ein kleines
grundstück ich habe und ich kann als er
nicht aber die damit schnell
ja das geht über schnell das ist fies
dieser starb das heißt ich muss mir eine
box mit mailbox ich glaube ich
sonst brauche ich meine paypal ab man
sollte das nicht gehen
komisch wie geht das nämlich so bob
balaban brechen so ich habe jetzt zwei
stuxnet freue ich mich ganz ganz
vorsichtig ihr kennt ja meine
erfahrungen und ich nehme mir auch im
bettchen jetzt mit für meine reisen
damit du dich niemand beschwert oder
ludwig aus müsste aus neugier ist ich
wieder zu fein um nach oben zu kommen
quoten aus lager quoten auslöser ist
zwar immer noch nicht aber mich kann
übrigens auch gar nicht pennen gehn
gerade auf mallorca - sowieso keine
rolle
kannst ja meine schafe scheren wenn ich
eine lava falle
jetpack rausfliegen
ich werde einfach irgendwann mal ball
doch nano dingsbums ausgehen und dann
gar nicht einfach durch das schaffen
kann dadurch mit links da kann man namen
trägt man kein feilschen wie summer und
ich finde einfach keine diamanten das
ist das problem
keine diamanten dort ist dass klopp hat
große prof dafür nicht erlauben das
kloster in der lava fallen ich brauchte
castiel ich soll mich sie zu fahren bloß
ohne sie zu fahren aber wenn es einen
lover fällt es trotzdem weg und sah war
so perfekt habe ich mich ja das ist
richtig geil mit diesem modus der kostet
zwar wirklich 10.000 energie blue ideen
was man abbaut welcher modus
ja diese dass dieser loslässt bei
electric vans kostet 10.000 das heißt du
musst ja einen leppek haben dass ich
wieder auflädt aber das zu 100 prozent
kann es nicht kaputt gehen sozusagen
post dass das geil ich habe oder
elektrik mensch warst du noch im bett
lag und dann go get back wollte ich mir
machen so jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob
ich habe schon mal 17 kloster zu alle
haben ihre häuser er richtig mies
ausgebaute ich hab gar nichts ja ich
werde mir bald auch noch heraus richtig
die beiden bauen sich ein gast über mich
live stream oder so muss mir mühe geben
weil sich scheiße ich ein gast gast
drum
wer von ihnen wo abgeschlossen
und es hakt es hake sagt alter ich habe
ich an solche ist ein dorf ich hasse den
never ich hab so angst thema muss
einfach jetzt mal eben wie im portal
machen ja hier sind gar schon mal einer
das gut nein doch nicht
ich habe auch vergessen wo das dings ist
also eigentlich sollte es ja in einem
dorf muss und im kgb das doch wohl schon
so heftig geplündert hätten
tödlich gegründete man jetzt schlägt er
dieser castro 84 labruce es geht
84 heißt für mich ach jetzt soll sie so
ich blende weil ich es mit dem laser und
fliegt dann einfach unter deutscher
fahne als laser auch auf auch auf
ich stecke ich direkt von gast
machen.foto mal ganz klar foto machte ja
und das genau im nächsten moment sich
direkt wie seine kugel einfach direkt
vor fittest und dem gast dann direkt vor
mir einfach alles anfängt zu bringen
ich hab das gefühl dieses nämlich soll
auch hat offenbar auch einen hohen wert
was diesen scanner angeht nicht mein
fall nicht mein fall
freunde sagt wie hölle hölle
also eigentlich braucht man ihn nur ab
12 gucken für die 12.000 habe ich so
meine ich arbeite hier echt am limit ich
könnte bear grylls mit 200 meisten der
uni graz conny grillt scheiß auf bear
grylls conny grillt ja jetzt ja gar nix
wenig freunde bei scanner alter ich höre
wird das an hier nur mist müssen da
fragt soll ist auch gut so viel von
dieser scheiße ich nicht mehr das machen
nur scheiße aber das war nicht der
verdienst ist gern mein verdienst
ich bin grad fast eine lava gefallen
sofort blutdruck wieder auf 1000 das
nenne ich doch herrlich habe ich schon
wieder 64 ist gefunden aber ich liebe
diese adrenalin moment ich liebe das
auch wenn man in der schule ist und fast
vom stuhl oliver bender und er ist halt
auch mal so einen anderen liegt das geil
finde ich der kick oder wenn man ihnen
die form von 5 am freibad springt oder
so und dann kurz luft ist da diese ganz
paar sekunden das osten gewitter
adrenalin-kick dann mein adrenalin kick
ist penis auerbach zu machen
jetzt spüre ich verletzten sind frei
walter die leute immerhin durch den coni
wird seinen grünschnitt muss portal
finden ich habe das läuft doch läuft ich
bin direkt unter portals cool ich gehe
ihm kurz wieder in die normale welt
doppeltes tonis tonis tony stone i nein
das ist doch ich bescheidene büßte leben
und ich komm raus cool ja ist gut dann
machen guten händen
bis zur nächsten folge leute macht gut
bis dann darauf